I think it's funny when we are given
advice to always put the customer first
that means employees come second
inherently if you're going to put a
customer first employees customers come
and go obviously we want to work to keep
them loyal but its employees who spend
more time at work than they do with
their families its employees who are
asking to give their blood and sweat and
tears to advance our vision and so it's
a leaders responsibility to take care of
the people first and the people will
take care of each other and the customer
any leader who prioritizes a customer
literally is saying I care more about an
external constituency than I do about
the people who are actually working here
the funny thing is a company like
Southwest Airlines a company like Costco
that are renowned for their customer
service as matters of policy do not
believe the customer's always right
they do not believe that the customer
comes first the irony is these great
customer service companies actually care
first
about their own people their employees
and they expect their employees to care
about their customers let me tell you a
story a true story some months ago I
stayed at the Four Seasons in Las Vegas
it is a wonderful hotel and the reason
it's a wonderful hotel is not because of
the fancy beds any hotel can buy a fancy
bed it's because of the people who work
there that when you walk the halls of
the Four Seasons and someone says hello
to you you really get the sense that
they wanted to say hello not that they
were told to say hello so in the lobby
of the Four Seasons they have a coffee
bar and one afternoon I went to buy a
cup of coffee and I happened to be
served by a barista named Noah Noah was
wonderful he was fantastic he was
friendly he was funny he was engaging I
think I ended up giving a hundred
percent tip and so as is my way I asked
Noah do you like your job here and Noah
said I love my job here so I followed up
and said what is it that the four
seasons is doing that would make you say
to me I love my job and without skipping
a beat he said throughout the day
managers will walk past me and ask me
how I'm doing they'll ask me if I need
anything to do my job any better he says
not just my manager any manager and then
he
something magical he said I also work at
Caesar's Palace and they're the managers
walk past and make sure we're doing
everything right they catch us up we're
doing anything wrong there I just try to
get through the day I keep my head below
the radar and I just want to cash my
paycheck same person and the customer
will have a different experience not
because of NOAA know is a good guy the
customer will have a different
experience because of how the management
regards NOAA today does management
believe NOAA is the number one priority
which is management believe that the
customer is the number-one priority and
again the irony is is it's the
organization that believes that NOAA is
more important that then NOAA is better
capable of taking care of the customer
it is a linear process and I think so
many people in business forget that yes
of course ultimately we want to be the
customer to be happy of course but the
methodology is actually to prioritize
the well-being of our people I think the
wrong thinking about customers comes
from the fact that we look at results
more than we look at process results are
much easier to measure and so we talk
about profit first but because it's easy
to measure you know we talked about we
prioritize literally money over trust
because how do you measure trust it's
more difficult same with customer
service you know the result would be
great customer service but the process
is the long hard work of building a
strong culture in which the people take
care of each other
so that they can take care of the
customer that it's more ethereal and
harder to measure I can measure customer
loyalty customer service and sales and
return business and things like that so
I think it's human nature to go to the
thing that we can easily see an easily
count and in the case of customer
service that would be the end product
not the process that got us there
[Music]